[تصفيق]
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تقدم نصيحه
لاوكرانيا بعنوان بوتين لا يلعب فلتحذر
والاوكران في مهب الريح ومعها ذا تضع
الولايات المتحده شروطا صعبه في وجه
زرنسكي هنغاريا ترفع رايه العداء امام
الاوكرانيين فما القصه الدفاع الروسيه
تعلن عن عدد مهول من ضحايا الجيش
الاوكراني خلال الشهر الجاري ومعارك الجو
تشتعل في السماء الاوكرانيه وهذه المره
باسلحه جديده وخليفه حفتر في ضيافه فما
الذي يجري من تحت الطاوله في كرباخ الوضع
يخرج عن السيطره وعشرات القتلى ومئات
الاصابات فماذا عن الهدنه الفلبين تتصدى
للصين في البحر الجنوبي بينما يعقد
اردوغان مشروعا مع الكيان الاسرائيلي فاين
ذهبت شعاراتك التي صدعت رؤوسنا بها عثمان
وللمره الاولى كوريا الجنوبيه ترد عسكريا
على جارتها الشماليه
ضيقه ارباك غير مسبوق توتر في التصريحات
مع قلق مما هو قادم الغرب يعيش ضغوطات
كبيره والسبب اوكرانيا يخرج المحلل السابق
بوكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويقول انه سيتعين على اوكرانيا التخلي عن
مقاطعات خرسون وزابرتشوا ودونيسكو لابرام
اتفاق سلام مع روسيا واكد انه اذا رفضت
القوات الاوكرانيه الاستسلام فان الجيش
الروسي سوف يستنزفها ويحمي اراضيها اي
باختصار لن تنتهي الحرب الا بالتخلي عن
المقاطعات التي سيطر عليها بوتين وعلى ذات
السياقه هو رئيس الوزراء الهنغاري فيكتور
اوروبا يرفع رايه العداء مع اوكرانيا
بالتاكيد ان بلا دوله تنوي الامت
باعاده المجندين اللاجئين كما لا تخططوا
لتخصيص اموال اضافيه من الاتحاد الاوروبي
لدعم الجيش الاوكراني ليزيد منسق لاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي
الطين بالله بتصريحه ان لدى الولايات
المتحده امكانيات لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكريه لعده اسابيع اخرى فقط
هل حان الوقت لترك اوكرانيا وحيده في
مواجهه الروس تاتي الاجابه من الاداره
الامريكيه حيث افادت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه
بان مايكل بيل نائب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي وجه الى القياده الاوكرانيه
قائمه الاصلاحات التي يجب تحقيقها من اجل
الحصول على المزيد من المساعدات ومن بين
المطالب الامريكيه الوارده في الرساله
اصلاح هيئه الجمارك وحرس الحدود
الاوكرانيين اضافه الى اصلاحات الشرطه
ووزاره الدفاع ومكتب الامن الاقتصادي
والمحكمه العليا محاربه الفساد وغيرها ما
الذي تبقى اذا فلتقل تغيير الدوله عن بكره
ابيها في المقابل صرح نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي بان الاحداث الاخيره المحيطه
بروسيا تترك لها خيارات اقل فاقل باستثناء
الصراع المباشر مع النيتو الذي تحول الى
كتله فاشيه بشكل علني انه يتحدث عن اقتراب
مواجهه نيتو ضد روسيا وبشكل مباشر وها نحن
ننتقل الى ميدان المعارك الاوكرانيه لكن
قبل ذلك توعد الكريم باحراق دبابات ابرز
الامريكيه في اوكرانيا معتبرا ان هذه
الدبابات لن تؤثر على مجريات الحرب وياتي
ذلك في اعقاب اعلان الرئيس الاوكراني
استلام الدفعه الاولى من دبابات التي
تعهدت بها واشنطن الى ذلك اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني ان روسيا استهدفت مناطق عده في
البلاد بثمانيه مسيره مشيرا الى انه 26
منها بالمقابل على نت روسيا اسقاط وتدمير
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه فوق منطقتي بالقرود
على حدود اوكرانيا كما اعلنت التصدي لهجوم
جوي واسقاط صاروخ قرب احدى القواعد الجويه
بشبه جزيره القرم اليكم المصدر الجويه
الاوكرانيه اعلى من الاسقاط 26 مسيره من
اصل 38 اطلقت على مناطق جنوبي ووسط البلاد
طبعا كان هناك استهداف
بالمسيرات تسبب باضرار كبيره في المرفا
وفي البنى التحتيه و 38 اطلقت على مناطق
جنوبي ووسط البلاد بينما شهدت عده مناطق
اوكرانيه هجمات روسيه بطائرات شاهد
الانتحاريه شملت
لتخلف اضرارا كبيره حيث اشتعلت النيران
بنحو 30 شاحنه في منطقه
وها هي مقاتلات سوق 34 الروسيات تدمر
مواقع تحسن القوات الاوكرانيه بالضربات
دقيقه بحسب المصدر امامكم
[موسيقى]
الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن ان الطيرانها دم
مقاتله اوكرانيه من طراز ميكس 29 في مطار
كلو بمقاطعه
وخمسين طائره مسيره في مناطق متفرقه خلال
يوم لتاتي حصيله الشهر بتصريح من وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو الذي اعلن ان خسائر
القوات الاوكرانيه منذ بدايه الشهر الحالي
شملت اكثر من 17 الف فرد و20700 قطعه من
الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه الارقام تتحدث
عن نفسها والمصدر يتحدث ايضا في الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه هنا تعود بنا
الاحداث مجددا نحو اذربيجان بعد ايام من
اعلان الهدنه اعلن انفصاليون في اقليمنا
جورنيكارباخ مقتل 20 شخصا واصابه نحو 280
اخرين لانفجار مستودع للوقود
الاحداث والتطورات البدايه من الفلبين
قالت من الا انها نفذت عمليه خاصه لازاله
حاجز غائم اقامته الصين في منطقه صيد
رئيسيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي وهي خطوه قد
تؤجج التوترات بعد انفراجه استمرت سنوات
في اكبر منطقه في اسيا الى تركيا قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على متن
الطائره خلال رحله عودته من اقليم نخت
شيفان الاذري ان بلاده ستتعاون مع اسرائيل
بالتنقيب عن الغاز في البحر الابيض
المتوسط وكشف اردونا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
قد يزور تركيا خلال اكتوبر او نوفمبر
المقبلين والسؤال هو هل نسي اردوغان
شعاراته الرنانه حول القضيه الفلسطينيه
الى ليبيا استقبل نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي
يونس بك روف المشرا الليبي خليفه حفتر في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو قوات حفتر في
صفحتها على فيسبوك الى ان المباحثات
ستتطرق الى تطورات الاوضاع في ليبيا
والعلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين وسبل
تعزيز دعمها وتطويرها والقضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشترك فهل تكون ليبيا الهدف
الافريقي القادمه لبوتين الى شبه الجزيره
الكوريه نظمت كوريا الجنوبيه اول عرض
عسكري لها منذ عشر سنوات لاستعراض
ترسالتها المتقدمه في وقت تتدهور فيه
العلاقات مع جارتها كوريا المسلحه نوويا
[موسيقى]